c'est la communauté, c'est le public.
Vous savez d'expérience que lorsque vous allez voir un film,
vous rentrez dans un cinéma et, s'il est vide, vous êtes ravi
car il n'y aura rien entre vous et le film.
Vous pouvez vous étaler, mettre vos jambes sur les sièges,
manger votre pop-corn et en profiter.
Mais si vous entrez dans un théâtre
et que vous voyez que le théâtre est à moitié plein,
votre cœur se serre.
Vous êtes immédiatement déçu
car, que vous le sachiez ou non,
vous veniez dans ce théâtre
pour faire partie d'un public.
Vous veniez pour avoir une expérience collective,
pour rire ensemble, pleurer ensemble, retenir votre souffle ensemble,
voir ce qu'il se passe ensuite.
Vous êtes peut-être entré dans ce théâtre en tant que consommateur individuel
mais si le théâtre joue son rôle,
vous en sortez avec un sentiment que vous faites partie d'un ensemble,
partie d'une communauté.
Cela est inscrit dans l'ADN de ma forme d'art.
Vingt-cinq siècles plus tard, Joe Papp a décidé
que la culture devrait appartenir à tout le monde aux États-Unis d'Amérique
et que c'était son rôle d'essayer de tenir cette promesse.
Il a créé Free Shakespeare in the Park.
Free Shakespeare in the Park est fondé sur une idée très simple :
le meilleur théâtre, le meilleur art que nous pouvons produire
devrait être accessible par tous et appartenir à tous
et, aujourd'hui encore,
tous les soirs d'été à Central Park,
2 000 personnes sont dans les gradins
pour voir le meilleur théâtre que nous pouvons offrir gratuitement.
Ce n'est pas une transaction commerciale.
En 1967, 13 ans après avoir compris cela,
il a compris autre chose :
le cercle démocratique n'était pas complet
simplement en offrant les classiques aux gens.
Nous devions laisser les gens créer leurs propres classiques
et monter sur scène.
En 1967,
Joe a ouvert le Public Theater en ville, sur l'Astor Place,
et la première pièce qu'il a produite fut la première mondiale de « Hair ».
C'est la première chose qu'il a faite en dehors de Shakespeare.
Clive Barnes dans The Times a dit que M. Papp avait pris un balai
et balayé tous les déchets des rues d'East Village
pour les amener sur scène au Public.
(Rires)
Ce n'était pas un compliment,
mais Joe l'a accroché dans le hall d'entrée,
il en était si fier.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Ce que le Public Theater a fait les années suivantes
avec des pièces géniales telles que
« For Colored Girls Who Have Considered Suicide / When the Rainbow Is Enuf »,
« Chorus Line »
et -- l'exemple le plus extraordinaire qui me vient à l'esprit :
le cri de rage sauvage de Larry Kramer au sujet de la crise du SIDA,
« The Normal Heart ».
Quand Joe a produit cette pièce en 1985,
il y avait plus d'informations au sujet du SIDA
dans la critique de Frank Rich dans le New York Times
que ce qu'en avait publié le New York Times
en quatre ans.
Larry a changé le dialogue au sujet du SIDA
en écrivant cette pièce
et Joe l'a produite.
J'ai eu la chance de diriger et travailler sur « Angels in America » de Tony Kushner
et durant cette pièce, ainsi qu'avec « The Normal Heart »,
nous pouvions voir que la culture changeait
et cela n'était pas dû au théâtre,
mais le théâtre jouait son rôle
pour changer ce que c'était d'être gay aux États-Unis.
J'en suis incroyablement fier.
(Applaudissements)
Quand j'ai pris la relève de Joe au Public en 2005,
j'ai réalisé qu'un des problèmes était d'être victime de notre succès :
Shakespeare in the Park avait été fondé comme un programme d'accès
et c'était maintenant le billet le plus difficile à obtenir de New York.
Des gens dormaient dehors pendant deux nuits pour obtenir un billet.
Qu'est-ce que je faisais ?
Cela empêchait 98% de la population
de ne serait-ce qu'envisager d'y aller.
Nous avons recréé l'unité mobile
et avons amené Shakespeare dans des prisons, des refuges,
des centres communautaires dans les cinq quartiers,
et dans le New Jersey, et dans le comté de Westchester.
Ce programme nous a démontré une chose que nous savions intuitivement :
le besoin de théâtre des gens est aussi fort que leur désir de nourriture
ou d'un verre.
Cela a été une réussite extraordinaire et nous avons continué.
Il y a encore une autre barrière que nous avons franchie sans le savoir,
la barrière de la participation.
L'idée était :
comment le théâtre pouvait-il passer d'une commodité, d'un objet,
et redevenir ce qu'il est vraiment :
un ensemble de relations entre des gens ?
Sous la direction du génial Lear deBessonet,
nous avons lancé le programme Public Works
qui, chaque été, produit
ces énormes spectacles musicaux shakespeariens
où des acteurs et musiciens ayant remporté un Tony
jouent aux côtés d'assistantes maternelles et d'employés de maison,
de vétérans et de prisonniers récemment incarcérés,
d'amateurs et de professionnels,
tous ensemble sur la même scène.
Ce n'est pas qu'un super programme social,
c'est le meilleur art que nous faisons.
La thèse à la base de cela est que le talent artistique
n'est pas détenu seulement par quelques-uns.
Le talent artistique est inhérent au fait d'être un être humain.
Certains passent simplement plus de temps durant leur vie à l'exercer.
Et occasionnellement --
(Applaudissements)
il y a un miracle tel que « Hamilton »,
l'adaptation extraordinaire de l'histoire de la fondation de notre pays
de Lin-Manuel
à travers les yeux du seul Père fondateur qui était un orphelin immigrant et bâtard
venant des Antilles.
Ce que Lin a fait,
c'est exactement ce que Shakespeare a fait.
Il a pris la voix du peuple, la langue du peuple,
l'a élevée en vers
et, ce faisant,
a ennobli la langue
et a ennobli les gens parlant la langue.
En ayant une distribution
entièrement composée de personnes noires et de couleur,
Lin nous a dit,
a ravivé en nous
nos plus grandes aspirations pour les États-Unis,
le meilleur de la nature de l'Amérique,
notre idée de ce que ce pays pourrait être,
l'inclusion qui était au cœur du rêve américain.
Cela a libéré une vague de patriotisme en moi
et au sein du public,
dont l'appétit se révèle insatiable.
Il y a une autre facette avec laquelle je veux terminer,
c'est la dernière histoire dont je veux parler.
Certains ont peut-être entendu que le vice-président Pence
est venu voir « Hamilton » à New York.
Quand il est entré, certains de mes camarades new-yorkais l'ont hué.
Admirablement, il a dit :
« C'est le bruit de la liberté. »
A la fin du spectacle,
nous avons lu ce qui me semble être une déclaration très respectueuse
et le vice-président Pence l'a écoutée
mais cela a suscité une certaine indignation, un déferlement de tweets,
et un boycott de « Hamilton » sur Internet
de la part des gens ayant eu l'impression que nous lui avions manqué de respect.
J'ai considéré ce boycott et j'ai dit que nous ne faisions pas ce qu'il fallait.
Tous ces gens ayant signé la pétition de boycott
n'auraient jamais vu « Hamilton » de toute façon.
Le spectacle ne passera jamais près de chez eux.
S'il passait, ils ne pourront pas payer le billet
et s'ils ont l'argent pour le billet, ils n'ont pas les relations
pour l'obtenir.
Ils ne nous boycottaient pas,
nous les avions boycottés.
Si vous regardez la carte électorale bleue et rouge des États-Unis
et si je vous disais
que le bleu désignait
les principales institutions culturelles à but non lucratif,
je vous dirais la vérité.
Vous me croiriez.
Nous avons fait dans la culture exactement ce que l'économie,
le système éducatif et la technologie ont fait :
tourner le dos à une grande partie du pays.
Cette idée d'inclusion doit persister.
A l'automne prochain, nous envoyons en tournée
une production de la géniale Lynn Nottage,
une pièce ayant reçu un prix Pulitzer : « Sweat ».
Des années de recherche à Redding, en Pennsylvanie,
l'ont poussée à écrire cette pièce
au sujet de la désindustrialisation de la Pennsylvanie :
ce qu'il s'est passé à la disparition de l'acier,
la rage provoquée,
les tensions provoquées,
le racisme provoqué
par la perte d'emplois.
Nous partons en tournée avec cette pièce
dans les comtés ruraux de la Pennsylvanie,
de l'Ohio, du Michigan,
du Minnesota et du Wisconsin.
Nous avons des partenariats avec des organisations communautaires
afin de nous assurer
de toucher les gens que nous voulons toucher,
mais aussi de trouver des façons de les écouter en retour
et de dire que la culture est également là pour eux.
Parce que --
(Applaudissements)
nous dans l'industrie de la culture,
nous au théâtre,
n'avons pas le droit de dire que nous ignorons quel est notre rôle.
C'est dans l'ADN de notre forme d'art.
Notre rôle est « d'être le miroir de la nature,
de montrer à la vertu ses propres traits,
à l'infamie sa propre image,
et au temps même sa forme et ses traits ».
Notre rôle est d'offrir à l'Amérique une image
qui montre non seulement qui nous sommes tous individuellement,
mais qui nous réunit au sein de cette communauté que nous devons être,
la notion d'unité,
la notion d'ensemble,
la notion de notre identité en tant que pays.
C'est cela que le théâtre est censé faire
et que nous devons essayer de faire autant que possible.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)